kaufman here
um today i want to do the first of three
videos
on what i call the um i've called them
the three keys let's call them the
tripod
the tripod of language learning it's a
attitude
t
time
and
n
the ability to notice
you could also call it attentiveness but
it's the ability to notice which is
something we develop i'm going to do a
video on each one because to me all of
language learning boils down to those
three letters a
t
and n
so today i'm going to talk about
attitude
uh i did a my i think my previous video
was about the difficulty that
chinese immigrants have in canada
the difficulty they have in learning
english and the study
showed that after seven years uh a
subgroup of people
of
mandarin speaking immigrants
actually made no progress in their
english after seven years
and
or very little progress and that a group
of slavic speakers russian ukrainian
whatever they were croatian
made much more progress
now there obviously are reasons relating
to how
mandarin is more diffic more different
from english than say slavic languages
but i think the biggest factor is
attitude
and so the first
element of attitude that i want to talk
about and as usual i haven't scripted
this out so i just ramble on here i
don't know
what is going to come first and second
but
um
chinese people
from china in particular uh
have trouble
coming out of their own
cultural
little world
they have a very strong what i would
call
cultural ego
they have trouble sort of achieving what
i have called cultural
weightlessness
in other words
rather than thinking that they are a
chinese person who is going to learn
this
foreign language
but remain a chinese person
they would be better off if they said
i'm a person some other group of people
are persons they speak another language
i can learn to speak it just as well as
them
i can be part of their group i want to
be part of their group it doesn't matter
who i am
uh when i go to learn china when i did
go to learn chinese i wanted to be
chinese
i didn't hang back in there in my
english speaking cultural world
and we see this as well amongst let's
say english-speaking people i find in
many ways english-speaking people not
not by no means all and there are many
many exceptions to this but as a general
rule there is this
cultural
centeredness
all the world should speak english isn't
it great that everyone speaks english
and therefore they have trouble
some of them many of them but but
certainly not all
just saying i'll connect with a chinese
speaker a spanish speaker a russian
speaker
people from smaller countries
ha in some cases i would say not always
have less of this cultural ego
now
it's not always true i mean i i would
say that the southern europeans and even
say if we contrast the french to the
germans the germans have less of this
cultural ego they're more prepared to
become
a spaniard or an italian or
something else
uh
and i'm gonna be subject to a lot of
criticism because this is the kind of
thing that doesn't apply to all people i
have met chinese people in china who
were absolutely fluent in three
languages and had never left the country
and were totally into learning those
cultures in those languages and the same
is true in france and i have met germans
and swedes who could only speak their
own language so there are always
exceptions so maybe i shouldn't
characterize it as specific to a
nationality but
the ability to
elevate yourself get above your own
culture and deliberately project
yourself into the new culture
and the desire to want to be part of
that culture and to find aspects of that
culture that you enjoy
that attitude is extremely important to
language learning if you can't find
something to enjoy you may still learn
it if there's a very strong necessity
but you won't learn it as easily
as the person who has this genuine
interest not tied to their culture of
origin but
totally committed to the culture the
language that they're trying to learn so
that is a very very important attitude
and all good learners have that cultural
weightlessness they want to pretend
they're russian or french or chinese or
japanese
so that's one
the other attitude part is
determination you have to will yourself
to learn a language
a book that i often refer to by jeffrey
schwartz called the mind and the brain
talks about how
the determination to
uh for example with patients who have
obsessive compulsive disorder
rather than taking drugs he can persuade
them that there is
activity in their brain
you know networks in their brain that
are causing them to behave in a certain
way and they can actually break that
but similarly with language learning if
you are very determined to learn then
you can create you can that helps you
create the necessary neural networks
to
learn the language
another aspect of attitude is your
confidence that you're going to succeed
as i've often said if you're trying to
climb a mountain and you don't think you
can reach the peak you have no idea
where the peak is
you're not likely going to get there
you're going to give up halfway
people who are confident and that's very
often the case with people have learned
more than one language confident that
they can achieve their goal
they're going to do better so you know
cultural weightlessness
will power
confidence
i mean part of their cultural weaknesses
is is a liking for that language okay
so those are all parts of the attitude
that you have to have
you have to have an attitude that you're
going to enjoy the activity anything
that you're enjoying you're going to
you're going to do better at
um
i don't know what i've left out but but
it's i think attitude is 70 percent of
the battle so the biggest reason why
these chinese immigrants in canada have
difficulty relates to attitude they
don't think they can do it they're in
many cases not so interested in they
would almost like to learn the language
without the people
because they're not so comfortable
interacting with with say canadians
so uh but i'm going to be spending some
time with different groups of chinese
immigrants over the next
few weeks here and i want to learn more
about their attitudes i'm going to ask
them i'm giving a speech in front of a
group of chinese immigrants i'm going to
get three or four of them up on stage
and ask them how do they react to relate
to english what are their feelings about
english what are their feelings about
communicating with people in canada in
english what are their feelings about
their own learning experience to try to
get at that attitude because i think
attitude is
is absolutely number one another thing
that's very important in terms of
attitude is
in my view not to be a perfectionist not
to get frustrated not to expect to
remember anything
to accept the fact that at first
everything is very foggy
and whatever you learn you forget
and you stumble when you try to speak
and you don't understand no matter how
many times you listen and none of this
should bother you it's part of the
process
attitude wise i think the thought that
that if you are exposing yourself to the
language if you are listening and
reading
putting in the effort you are going to
improve the brain learns all the time
the brain learns all the time there are
things that we can do to help it learn
but it learns all the time so you need
to have that
confidence
that you are learning and not to get
frustrated when
there because the brain learns all the
time but it learns slowly and so we have
to be patient with the brain the brain
takes its time to learn so all of those
attitudinal things
cultural weightlessness you know many
people resist the language i mean how
many times do i hear people say oh why
do they say it that way in that language
or people who will deliberately
translate
um you know sayings or expressions from
their own language they think it's
clever to to translate say this in the
english earth if it's an english
expression translated into french but
you have to leave that behind you have
to leave your own language behind
you have to imitate
the cultural behavior of this other
group the further away you get from your
own language the better i mean you need
the language for the dictionary and
stuff like that
so all of these attitudinal things i
think is a that is like 70 of the battle
cultural weightlessness
confidence
not allowing yourself to be frustrated
not resisting the language not asking a
bunch of questions all the time why do
they say it this way why do they say it
that way
and trusting your brain that the brain
will learn if you give it enough time
and exposure
but recognizing the brain learns slowly
and of course enjoying the the course so
the three
feet of the tripod are attitude
time
and and
noticing so in my next video i will talk
about time how do we find the time and
we need a lot of time so thanks for
listening bye for now